[Music]
Larry Corey: I think the companies who are in the
COVID vaccine space recognize that
there's room for everybody to be successful.
Their global business is also being disturbed
by what's happening with COVID-19.
We need it in North America and South America and Europe and Africa and Asia.
So it's the entire globe.
Getting as many doses as you can manufactured in anticipation
of it being successful, and sometimes the U.S. government may buy
doses beforehand to cover some of those
manufacturing costs
or subsidize some of those manufacturing costs.
How do you scale manufacturing so that you
actually reserve all the manufacturing facilities
that you can possibly have through strategic alliances
not just with the big pharma companies but all
the other companies that could actually
manufacture this kind of technology.
And then we need to think about, well, how
would we distribute it as quickly as we
can to get it in people's arms.
Number one: by having a common data safety monitoring board
that takes responsibility, that will view each trial
both independently but in the context of
other trials as far as its safety and effectiveness.
By having essentially the National Institutes support it.
There's a commitment to make the results available
in a very transparent fashion and not
one that's associated with any commercialism.
To put any individual trial in context:
where has this individual trial done better or equal to
other individual trials, where are the unique
aspects of it.
The better the clinical trial,
the more applicable it can be for policy.
In the end,
policy needs to be translated out of clinical trials.